this comment was put under a video
where I was talking about race
and how white leaders can create
an inclusive environment for people of color
and she saying that
I seem genuinely interested
in helping white people understand culture
first of all
thank you so much for this comment
I don't specialize in diversity
equity and inclusion
but I am certified in it
and while I do not speak for all Black people
or people of color
I am happy to
try to answer questions
if you are white
you are a leader
and you have questions
about how to properly serve other people
specifically
people of color
if you have questions
about how to be inclusive
or how to get rid of unconscious bias
drop them below
and I'll try my best to answer those
here on TikTok
I have a very diverse following
and I wanna make sure I create
a safe environment for you to ask questions
so feel free to do so